have you seen this blog post called what
time is it in Silicon Valley yeah was
the clock yeah said it's basically it
describes what you're talking about
which is this guy who was doing like PR
or comms for tech companies for a long
time he's like a you know I've been
through this cycle five times now this
is how it works it's like imagine a
clock and you know from midnight to 1:00
a.m. it's like okay this new thing is
born oh this is interesting that's the
narrative and then as you get to sort of
like three you know three o'clock it's
like ooh this is the shiny new fun thing
to play with everybody talks about it
everybody has opinion of it everybody
wants to show their friend this thing
because it's the new thing and then when
you get by the time you get to four or
five people start to the narrative
changes to like hey this is not just a
toy this could be something big
and by 6 p.m. you know you know the
clock hand it's gone half way around by
6 p.m. it's like this is gonna change
the world
and that's like right now the company
going through this is lambda school
where it started yeah this little boot
camp then it was like holy this is
gonna disrupt universities and then if
you've noticed in the last month there's
all this press coming out in some ways
rightfully so because they make mistakes
as they grow and whatnot but some of
these things were always there it's just
a narrative change so by 7:00 p.m. it
starts to be like hey you know what it's
not as good as everyone says actually
the product kind of sucks you know what
this founder is like doesn't know what
the hell they're doing this things about
to crash and then it goes through this
cycle of rebirth and so now once you
read that post and then you start
reading the news you start to just see
that everywhere it's like oh this is the
hype cycle it's going you know you can
just tell what what hour of the clock
are we in and it's like you know not to
use the pun but it's like clockwork it's
just you see it happening over and over
again yeah and then and I read a lot of
history books it happens like that like
Rockefeller had the same thing anti
billionaire anti-this anti-that it's
cyclical so this isn't anything new yeah
build you up they break you down and if
you're if you're in that company you
just got to know this is these are the
waves to be expected you shouldn't be
surprised and reacting when it happens
and if you're the reader like you know
the stuff is entertaining but like don't
just go for the ride and if you're gonna
be successful you're gonna you gotta go
you gotta get a you're gonna get a lot
of hate yeah like on this little podcast
and the con
section we get called we get made fun of
all the time not enough hate I would
like more hate actually but we've been
called ugly ugly some guy wrote like
when we started doin video they were
like hey audio guys haha yeah and then
another guy was like you know you should
show a background video of whatever
they're talking about because I don't
want to look at these fools
[Laughter]
[Music]